we now need to let these young people
know that they have been do you know we
we have we have kind of let our guard
down and and this is kind of segue for
that where we let our guard down so it's
probably the most important place we can
think about and saw the educational
system as we've been kind of moving on
and having our big dreams and you're
being your eternal optimist that we are
as a country building our future our
kids and and and vacation we have not
understood that evils been at our
doorstep every single step of the way
they have gotten into our educational
system for decades and they have eaten
away like little termites on the most
important thing that we can we can have
to keep our future and knowledge of our
past what we've done together and most
importantly what makes our country work
the free market we have kids coming out
of college hating our country because of
the about Marxist laboratories if we've
been together for the last few decades
[Music]
I'm Dave Rubin and this is the Rubin
report reminder everybody to subscribe
to our YouTube channel and click that
pesky notification bell so that you're
alerted when our new videos drop and
joining me today is a former NFL star
and Super Bowl champion now running for
Congress in Utah's fourth district
Burgess Owens welcome to the Rubin
report Dave thanks so much looking
forward to our chat for sure I'm glad to
have you man because you are blowing up
every time I turn on television now I
just did the Greg Gutfeld show with you
a couple days ago but every time I see
somebody talking on Twitter a video of
somebody doing something you're you seem
to be right in the middle of things
you're you're enjoying this little I
really am I really am because you know
we're having a conversation that's been
long overdue day but you know we've been
talking to hypothetically what could
happen with socialism Marxism I mean
this it's a conversation in half four
years and really not get through we have
an opportunity right now to let people
know this is the way it looks when you
give left power they have no clue to
deal with it other than to abuse it so I
think this is obviously it's tough times
but what I've come to understand about
America and I know our history and we go
through the toughest of times and snows
we as long as we know what the endgame
is what it takes to win we've come
together we put aside our differences
for a little bit of time and we go out
there and make things
happen so I see this is a great
opportunity to talk with our Democratic
minutes to love our country to our black
business owners for sure they definitely
get it and then those who have in the
past not been really engaged
we are literally fighting for the
hardest of our nation and those guys on
other side are totally there there
they're going nuts because they realize
how close they are to losing at all so
they are all hands on board and just
know that this will be a probably most
important few months we have coming up
in front of us now we just make sure we
take advantage of it and just and as Oh
Al Davis just to stay in old days just
win baby we need to get that done just
win baby so that's actually partly why I
wanted to have yann because because of
your history as an athlete as an NFL
player and even the way you answered
that question there's there's always a
certain rhythm which I've always loved
the way so many athletes speak about
things and and obviously you have some
of that and and I think we sort of need
a little bit more of that right now
people who know how to win not not win
at all costs but win within a certain
framework of rules and respect for each
other and respect for the country and I
really sense that out of you and I'll
tell you what I'm excited about I've
been hearing from a lot of my peers
though college peers and NFL peers but
when we came to a time when it's quite
different we came to a time where our
parents did such a great job and this is
the thing that I think is being lost we
have had this last generation the great
generation was truly remarkable they
succeeded in so many different ways and
to say that they were half this and
hopeless and oppressed as they is a is a
put-down to them in a big big way but
what I've been getting is calls from our
guys that I came through the college and
pro and they're all on board we'd love
the fact we're now talking about
standing for a flag standing for our
country respect which we were taught by
our parents to do and we now need to let
these young people know that they have
been do you know we we have we have kind
of let our guard down and and this is
kind of segue for that where we let our
guard down so it's probably the most
important place we can think about and
saw the educational system as we've been
kind of moving on and have no big dreams
and you'll be near eternal optimist that
we are as a country building our future
our kids and-and-and vacation we have
not understood that evils been on our
doorstep every single step of the way
they have gotten into our educate
system for decades and they have eaten
away like little termites on the most
important thing the weekend we can have
to keep our future and knowledge of our
past what we've done together and most
importantly what makes our country work
the free market we have kids coming out
of college hating our country because of
the about Marxist laboratories that we
even put together for the last few
decades so so this is a good time for us
even to start addressing that issue one
of the things I cannot wait to do and
we're gonna get the Congress by the way
let me just give you guys a little quick
advertisement Burgess for Utah comm
Burgess for Utah
go there all right I always be I promise
yeah I was gonna do it at the end let's
back up a little bit cuz you hit a
couple turns there so you mentioned the
greatest generation and and you're
talking about how so much of what's
happening now seems to be an erasure of
past so you thought you've had a pretty
amazing pass you were one of the first
three black football players at
University of Miami everybody knows
about the incredible football history
there can you just back up first and
just tell us a little bit about where
you're from what you what your folks
were like just growing up all I love to
I would love to because this is probably
the biggest pride I have is my
upbringing and and because so many
people don't know about it it's a
shocker it's important to realize but
the message of my background my
background is very simply this this
country will give anyone the opportunity
to get to the middle class if we will
understand the tenants that we need to
get there and it doesn't matter how poor
we come what color we are how little we
understand language if we understand
it's all about education faith industry
and family we got it so that being said
my are the black community because they
understood those tenets the 40s 50s and
60s led our country in the growth in
middle class men matriculated with
college men committed to marriage it was
70 percent and in percentage of
entrepreneurs we had now communities
business owners everywhere kids my doing
know white people might in my community
so everything was driven by by black
entrepreneurs that where'd you go
where'd you grow up and tallahassee
tallahassee florida deep south
tallahassee days with KKK Jim Crow
segregation I didn't have my first
interaction with white Americans until I
was 16 years old but I grew up in a
community it was so
who they were how dads came back war
they were proud of who they were I was
taught never let that flag touch the
ground it'll be desecrated it was really
proud of that but the most important
thing is that the 40% of business
ownership equated to over 50 to 60
percent of black Americans across our
country DC that South Texas California
we had relatives all across the board
all part of the middle class and that
was the way our country was our race was
that has been flipped upside down where
we now have 3.8% business ownership and
that's of course our middle class is
going down and unfortunately most
important thing about the middle class
most of it now has become elitist of a
great big group of elitist
a bigger group of poor and a very small
group of that very empathetic loving
serving outside the box thinking
middle-class so we have to get that back
and Dave I'll tell you if I can just
warn our fellow Americans what we're
what the real attack is the real value
we're fighting right now obviously is
our culture but what the left wants to
do is destroy our middle class why
because the middle class is a
stakeholder of our culture that's we
find the best of Americans those who's
going out there they work they pay that
they pay their bills they pay their
payroll they dream they're fill that
stump back up again and their goal is
verson to build something and give to
their kids a legacy and here's other
piece of it
business owners realize one thing when
when customers come through that door
they know what they have a discipline to
be a nice person why cuz they wanted to
come back again even if they're
knuckleheads they want to come back and
keep buying this product that is the
nest inspire other people to our country
the big of that middle class is the more
vibrant our freedom really is and the
more educated we are in the whole bit
and that's what they're after
that's where we look at their Kolbert
what they were trying to do these
Marxist these these folks who are
totally heartless because they've never
understood where there's a build of
business they wanted to shut down our
economy shut down business and make they
make sure they fail why because the end
of the day they want a power in November
they allow these mayors allow these
thugs that come through these these
black communities and every four years
destroy them destroy the infrastructure
why because that those black business
owners will become there lifting
themselves out of that popular to the
middle class
so this is what we're after if we
understand that then we understand our
enemy and enemy it's not us it's not
it's not a Republicans and Democrats
independence is those who truly adhere
to an evil ideology of socialism Marxism
and because they do they can care less
they have no heart for anybody else but
themselves and they don't mind and in my
case with the black community they will
use abuse and discard because that's
what it takes for them to continue to
win their battle as somebody that grew
up in the segregated south Jim Crow laws
and you mentioned you didn't really have
interactions with with white America
let's say till you're 16 years old you
know then you become a NFL star you
playing in college NFL star Super Bowl
champion have done all sorts of other
stuff since then are you shocked that in
2020 right now as we talk that we
seemingly at our are at our what the
media would tell you is our worst race
race relations in decades I don't think
it's actually true I think it's just the
way that it's being framed and pushed on
us but but are you shocked it's sort of
the moment that we're at right now well
I guess I can't say I'm shocked because
I know the the enemy is tenacious they
are they they just don't give up there's
no shame so so without what I think
we're finding out though is how deep
into our entire institutions that they
have given the dive gotten into when I
talk about termites they've been doing
this for a long time I've seen it with
the with our educational system I just
had no idea or how broad their the
tentacles work so we're seeing it coming
from every single angle that you have
including within our office to the
government that we thought we trusted
you know I never thought that the FBI
the DOJ all those things were were
complicit in this process but then if we
understand again a little bit about
Marxism and they're socialists they're
cowards and bullies so really shouldn't
be surprised they're the ones they're
gonna try to find this office place to
do their business to do their job they
want to you want to keep covered they
don't want to be fired so if they find a
place that's very safe
you'll find them whether it be a college
a college or tenure or these are you
know these these government jobs where
nobody knows who they are and they never
didn't ever get fired or of course the
media where they get into media
organizations will all have to do is be
as far left as you can and they got
expense your tits your job so that
that's what we're fighting against and
the downside to being entrepreneurs been
doing those who are eternal optimist we
sometimes forget to get into the weeds
you know we're we're not going to be
drawn to the same things there are we're
out there taking risk meal building our
dreams falling and getting back up and
all we want to be done is just be left
alone let us do our thing and just leave
us alone well while we're doing that
then behind the curtains all this is
going on okay and uh that's what the
fundamental do you think that's what the
fundamental disconnect in society right
now is I think it has something to do
with that that there's a certain set of
people
I actually think most Americans who just
want to live and let live they want some
basic policies that keep the government
out of their lives but that's pretty
much it
but when you believe that you're not
going to be riled up all the time and
angry and on the attack on time and now
we have a new set of people I don't
think it's as many as the other but I
think that they're they're loud and
vociferous and and on the attack and so
they seem disproportionately powerful
because the rest of us were working were
watching TV we're doing stuff with our
families whatever it might be so that
there's a disconnect there in the in the
parody a both sides it it is but that's
the nature of of who we are and it takes
keep in mind remember what we're doing
9/11 and a Pearl Harbor we were going
about our business and one day we all
Saturday is going to church or going to
work we had no idea how many how much
who were hated until thousands of us had
to die through our process but what
happens once the enemy hits we wake up
and realized we were up against and
that's when we become dangerous that's
the tour to the enemy as the the
Japanese whatever Admiral said I feel
with waking a sleeping giant I believe
what's happened right now they're
Americans across this country do not
like what they're saying they don't want
to see cities burn they don't wanna see
people getting beat up they we hate
bullies
to our core and we might mean that might
not be saying anything about it we might
not be polling because we just we just
aren't into that but we as a country
always do the right things at the right
time for the right reasons I personally
think Dave the reason why President
Trump can electron was was elected in
2016 because we as a country just
innately understood something wasn't
right
we never we definitely don't want the
other person to win even though we
didn't know a lot about president Trump
but at the end of the day now that we do
see it and we see him standing for for
rule of law we see them pulling together
the the free market and the government
working things out when more important
we see him working against these bullies
that no other president has done this
Reagan I mean Reagan had a different
style about it because they weren't is
his I guess mean I don't know word for
it or war but but but he's a guy that
the only one right now and I understand
could ever do what he's doing every
single day getting up because these guys
again or relentless and they have no
shame
and and they just love to live at the
end of the day just for them lying is
part of getting to the endgame
so we have to understand I think that's
what our country is getting to and
actually believe Dave that we're gonna
come out of this just fine I think for
the first time that's why as I'm running
for Congress which I never ever thought
out of the deal but I'm working with
kids my mission has always been working
with at-risk kids that's what I was
doing but I realized if we don't win I
packed a house the kids that work with
and across the country don't I don't
have a chance because it's always
policies that make them illiterate
hopeless jobless angry it's always
policies as Democratic Party's policies
are doing that so it's a way I see this
very simply we have about 18 19 seats we
need I'm looking across the country I've
seen these these congressional
candidates and they're like me many of
them have never done this before
but they're not going there to get a
permanent seat in Congress or to be a
lobbyist down the road they're there to
ripple replicate the president who's
showing us what true American loving
leadership looks like but a first time
for many of us to see what it takes to
really fight against the bullies we're
gonna get this new group in there and
we're gonna make changes that we have
never seen before because they're there
for the right reasons we're going to
start tackling things that we've always
had to
we've had either deal with elitist
Republicans or Lisa's Democrats and
nothing ever gets done when you talk
with those kind of people we're gonna
start looking at our budget balancing
our budget I'll do it something without
health care system gives it a
transparency and an a competitive nature
that brings it down
how about Social Security being able to
figure out how we keep our promises
where those who are older and had
promises made and give our young people
an opportunity to do something so much
better by the time they get to
retirement because they can own the
process those are conversations are
gonna finally have so we'll come there
and I'll call I'm gonna call I'm gonna
put this out there I see us as a SEAL
team the seals and we're there to really
there to disrupt some stuff and we'll
make that happen and not only will our
presence strengthen the backbone of our
Senate which we need more backbone but
allow our prisons for the first time in
four years to run forward without having
his hands tied behind his back
but I see this is this could be the
greatest renaissance for our country
that we've ever seen because all of the
country all of American can take part no
matter what the color creed a background
we can all be part of this new growth of
America and really and just really just
enjoy the process together you know it's
funny you describe it as a SEAL team
because I had Dan Crenshaw congressman
down in Texas who I'm sure you know and
I had him on and I described him it's
like you know he's like a solo superhero
fighting against the squad you know
they've got their Legion of Doom team
but he's kind of a solo guy and he needs
some some new help in in Congress and I
think that's what you're talking about
before we go too much on the policy side
because I was on your website this
morning
and you lay out all your political
beliefs actually very clearly it's all
there but before we do the policy stuff
I just want to do a little bit more on
your history because as I said earlier
you one of the three first black people
football players at University of Miami
and then let's talk a little bit about
NFL and just sort of how the how the
sports mindset and and going for a
championship and winning and all that
stuff how that set you up as a human
being okay good question let me let me
this first of all kind of put in context
the environment of NFL when I when I
when I when I joined as opposed to today
because I think the biggest part of us
being sad about
future is knowing about our past and if
something with Karl Marx said that said
it all
the first battleground is rewriting in
history if they steal our past we truly
do not have an appreciation where we are
and we have no vision for we're going
beeps okay so that being context again I
grew up in the deep south days of
segregation twelve years old I remember
marching I was the youngest person at
that time because with the thought
Indian when my dad was a college
professor in front of state Florida
State Theater because we couldn't go
into to look at a movie state of there
my dad just a little extra background my
dad actually came back from war very
proud proud World War two bad could not
go to get his postgraduate down in Texas
because of the Jim Crow laws and I
remember running across a box of letters
when he passed away of all these
rejection letters that had gotten across
the country that would not accept him to
those colleges and I looked doing that
and I realized was a racist thing but he
never ever brought it out he never
talked about it for him it was his
motivation and that's what those folks
doing there was motivation he ended up
going to a house they were his guys PhD
gonna end up being a 40-year a professor
there and was an entrepreneurial
research that we traveled around the
world I was five years old living in
Liberia Africa
that's the again that's the environment
this is the 50s had an older and older
uncle the Brotherhood he he and his
older brother both got their PhDs at
Ohio State they I got an agronomy uncle
irrigated and economics and of teaching
and Universal Houston the oldest brother
was probably the smartest one he was an
engineer and he loved planes but he can
do that when he was a service so he on a
part-time basis into buying a little
this in 1962 nobody bought planes in
1962 particular black folks but the
body'll own plane and because his
entrepreneurial he was an engineer but
he lived in Wichita Falls Texas
he took letters from Wichita Falls based
the military based in Chicago that was
just a town business the first FedEx and
then I remember him coming flying to to
Tallahassee and I must be maybe 12 years
old when I had my first flight in an
airplane and my really experienced bird
will cause he took us up they took me up
and I don't know if you know what the
era with the stall and sure you know
what stall means what
all about but if you don't know what a
stall means is it's good to know before
you start before you get experience it
feels like falling out of the air and I
remember stalling getting panicked and
kind of get control smiled at me and
taught me what airplane lift was I know
today exactly what airplane lift means
so but I'm not either way
no no I'm making that point because I
want people to know that my community
was truly one of the most competitive
communities in our country when they was
so proud of we educated ourselves cuz we
knew that's what we need to do to prove
to compete my degree was in biology my
minor was chemistry thing why did I was
able comfortable do that because my dad
was a cosmic master he had a laboratory
I feel very comfortable and the most
important thing is when I was told by
someone in high school that could not do
that I made it my duty I lived in the
library University of Miami to prove
that guy wrong because that's the
attitude we had those days so so that
was the environment again I went to
universe in Miami I was a I was drafted
through the Jets when I got to the Jets
this is this the way it was in those
days there was no black quarterbacks
centers free safeties or middle
linebackers in those days the message of
the Democratic Party was the black
people couldn't think we were not
leaders we could run with a job we can
play music but thinking was not out of
it was out of our I will house by the
way to that point when you go back and
see Martin Luther King you see the
marching I'm watching now to keep this
in context when you see them notice he
has white white shirts black ties
sometimes business caps and always
business shoes because they were going
against the narrative of the leftist of
the the racist of illiterate lazy
bumpkins can't talk all the negatives
you can possibly think of and they were
showing and the way they marched in a
disciplined and nonviolent that they
were totally off base and they wanted to
make sure their kids understood that not
to take the narrative of these people
you're not to be proud of who you are so
I I just want to put that in there
though so when I think back about when I
came in at FL what your what your rookie
year those 19 1973 1973 I
now look at an NFL now that's based on
meritocracy color doesn't matter that
means no matter what color you are how
how how big your if you can bring merit
to that team you'll get yourself a good
contract that speaks volumes if people
understand how far we've come then all
of a sudden damn we erased this place
doesn't work anymore I mean I know what
racism looked like I know what systemic
racism looks like we have an opportunity
right now to do anything we want to
actually not only go into a theatre I
can own a series of them if I wanted to
but it comes down to recognizing that
the differential and every single race
every single person transics obsessed is
based on those sport tennis very simple
to understand I think it's time that we
find a way to explain conservatism
explained the American Way the artery to
the middle class template we spent too
much time trying to debate it it comes
into for tennis head heart hands at home
education faith industry and family is
that simple if we educate ourselves
we're no longer could be be manipulated
by the leftist who wants to keep us dumb
and motivated by the notion if we
understand the faith is the answer to
everything this is the country was built
on judeo-christian values period and no
matter how we worship Him the reason why
we look at each other inside out versus
outside in better than any other country
because we believe there's a God in
heaven that makes us want to bless we
want the blessings by blessing others
industry we now understand as a country
that we're not that country that wants a
ten ten months vacation that's just not
us we want to work we want to sweat we
want to we want a man fall flat and get
back up because we feel good about the
process that's who we are that's what
we've always laid out the entire world
in terms of producing things that's
that's in a DNA of our American people
the last but not least is our family the
family unit it takes how where our
country goes and how we have for how we
fly and that's why that's why the left
has been after us for a long time
destroyed the family unit we should
always think about verse snowflake the
way else brought up is the best thing I
could do is is I want to I want to make
sure that my family's name is one that's
respected it's the legacy of my dad my
mom if I do if I do the kind of things
were their product that I that carry
their name and I do the same through my
kid
that we have not we have done a great
deep for our country and putting my for
my family and for my racing but my as a
citizen that all works out so the family
is really the key point and it we just
have to get back to understand what that
reason what the what the roles might be
and all that kind of stuff as a long
answer short question but I hope
everybody I think you got there I think
you got there so you mentioned the
meritocracy of the NFL now and I think
that goes obviously for all professional
sports at this point nobody cares what
color you are it's can you play I mean
and for me I'm a basketball guy but when
I when I play ball my entire life any
court that I showed up to nobody cared
if you were white or black or Asian or
anything else what do you care about can
the guy put the ball in the hole that's
that's the only thing that you care
about gender baby
yeah just win baby that's it but there's
a certain beauty and a simplicity to
that but when you see things you know
how politicized sports has become so you
may remember about a year ago there was
a big thing in the NBA that they didn't
want the players didn't want the owners
to call them owners because that somehow
had some connotations to slavery or
something but the simple fact is they
they own the team I mean they own the
team that that's how it works that when
you hear these things and and you hear
it from people that are Multi multi
millionaires that make money that you
could never do it do you remember how
much you made your work a year oh I'm
almost ashamed or keep in mind
first-round draft to us
get ready personal draft shows the third
13th pick the first defensive back my
bonus was 50 thousands a year from
50,000 and I made 20 23 25 27 the first
three is it and those last three those
who those years were not guaranteed by
the way have to go ahead and make that
happen but no now guys now guys great
like an eight year guaranteed hundred
million but really when you when you
hear these guys say these sorts of
things and and fight about these sorts
of things well and then suddenly they
won't say anything about China at the
same exact time we had a big problem
with that in the NBA because they want
lucrative deals over there in contract
and all that what do you make it as far
as what's happened in the sports world
there's two things there's two parts of
it I'm going to
I'm gonna highlight the the the middle
class once and then I'll get back to the
culture piece the first thing is this
this is with the biggest problem with my
community my race is that we went to
this great middle class built on small
business ownership to a great elitist
class built a little entertainment and
government when people do not do not
work their way through the middle class
and understand what it takes to make it
just to to strive to finally get to
where you feel comfortable can reach
back then you becoming leaders and what
happened to go from dirt poor to super
rich you really do believe you're all
that I mean it's very easy to get into
that mindset that you truly are you know
what answers well don't think about
LeBron LeBron knows he's a great
basketball player but he also knows the
answers to everything else the guy is so
smart if you ask him he's so bold and
he's never wrong but that's what happens
with elitist there's no there's not
pretty quiet on China though don't
forget Charlie suddenly didn't he didn't
know much yeah oh yeah oh yeah so that's
that's the one piece is unfortunately we
have we have we have too many latest who
don't get it and they will never
understand we're trying to go through
the other part of this is very simply
our coach has been under attack for a
long time when you take away the family
you take away God faith of God you take
away things they're simple things like
respect one thing that we had known
about community a day very simply
respect a God country family and most of
all women never ever don't even let that
thought go through your mind even
started going through a year of
disrespect the mob because that would be
there to take to make it right
big time so so when you don't understand
those basic respects you don't
understand that when you when you're
dealing with a coach he's truly the
coach I mean we came to an era what
Coach was there you know he told you
something this is there an argument
fight with him
we have a thing where things have turned
upside down we're literally the the
players are driving the team the players
are dictated to the the the the
Commissioner what they're gonna do what
they're not gonna do and of course we
have towers like the commissioner whose
and I'm gonna talk about this but
goredale is nothing but he's going to be
known in history as the they build de
Blasio of commissioners
this guy is as hapless and a half the
problem is that it's on purpose because
he's truly a true leftist that wants to
use the sport to push the agenda and
make and make it work out so at the end
of the day they get Democrats in place
it's all about power when you build
these leftist and Blasio I'm now started
gödel there's no difference
he's all about power he wants to use
these kids who have no clue dive into
the social justice was nothing but
Marxism so that we're creating all this
anger and angst and riots within the
community so they go out and vote in
November
these people are truly heartless they're
there and they and they don't think
they'll ever be found out cuz they're
always hiding behind the curtain but we
know we're gonna understand what this
person is this person driving it to the
NFL and I'll tell you what if they if
they if they know the route or what they
did before either kneeling or the latest
thing I've heard is gonna put the black
matter black lives matter flag pollutant
beneath our flag if you do it does
either one of those two we're done
with NFL we won't be coming back and
that's gonna be a good good thing to see
happen you know it's such a it's such a
crazy thing for I mean for a Super Bowl
champion football player to say that
that would be a good thing it's it's
crazy but I understand where you're
coming from but are you ever shocked I
mean I get what your feelings are about
about the Marxists and the idea of
destruction and all that but are you
ever shocked at a guy like Goodell who I
assume enjoys football I assume he
enjoys business right he may have the
wrong ideas but I think you know if we
separate that for a second but the
lengths that they'll go to destroy their
own enterprise I mean I think we see
this we see this across the the sports
but it does seem to be worse in the NFL
I think David Silver's done a much
better job in the NBA of sort of keeping
the wheels on the thing although we
talked about the China thing a moment
ago baseball for some reason they don't
seem to have major issues with this
there's something going on in the NFL
that does seem particularly different
I'm gonna give you a little insight of
what's happening I think you'll get it I
think you'll understand that as we play
check checkers they please guys play
chess
Goodell is a globalist globalist and a
globalist is someone who
looks themselves a they is a a world
citizen versus American citizen and in
their in their game as long as they can
get as many as much money coming in from
wherever they might get it they're okay
and what's happened is over the last few
years the NFL has been looking at
they're going to other other other parts
of the country China being one they have
they have little China teams that
working on they're now going to England
I had looking to have a Super Bowl there
in another couple years so they see a
global a global market it's gonna be
right now they've capped out around 14
billion he's projected by 2020 27
through up to the 25 billion now where
are they gonna get that extra it's not
here in America because they're pretty
much capped out is that is that TV is
that the global process and here's the
biggest part about it because it's not
just the global fat faster that that is
you know we can kind understand as a
business owner for these guys is more
than that they have to devalue the NFL
brand first before China will accept it
the be NFL brand is All American it's a
flag as our country I mean that's why we
stand together because we understand
this this is a matter of fact that the
founders are there to fail well most of
them were World War two vets so when
they came out and it developed this this
concept bills all about country well if
we're gonna do this in China they have
to demean that brand a little bit and so
that's why right now Nike which is the
marketing arm for NFL that's what did
the face of the NFL is now and around
the world its company the Marxist
carpeted he was paid that's at this pace
is there so so when it comes down to
branding now they can now make the money
they have to make outside of our country
and and of course keep the American
people moving on and keep the kind of a
solid base here one of the things are
they just you know the last contract is
sound for 40 million dollars per year
ninety percent of that is based on
growth incentives ninety percent so
that's there's a lot about he feels very
comfortable he felt very confident that
he could make enough money some kind of
way to growth to bring that kind of
income in and in the day with with the
the the kind of the the problem right
now it's China get their deal and also
China's not too attractive anymore and
it's gonna kind of upset to our aplicar
but I think it might have to reconsider
housing to get that done but if that's
the if you understand that process that
these people truly are nothing the way
we do as Americans that love our country
they think in a different way then maybe
you understand why they're why they
don't mind turning off the American fan
to make more income and look at the
global mark a little bit a little
different way it's so interesting
because obviously you know I know I know
about globalists and the idea of one
world and all that but I've never heard
the framing relative to the NFL that
we've got to grow we have these
projections we got to do it we we've
maxed out America so now we have to sort
of crush our own brand in a weird way to
export it over there it's it's pretty
fascinating and then the 40 million if
it's if it's mostly on incentives you
can you can sort of see how whacked out
so all right let's let's move a little
bit here okay - let's talk about Utah
because I've had a couple people from
the great state of Utah on and I've only
been to Utah once actually when I was on
tour with Jordan Peterson a year or two
ago and we did a show there and I did
some stand-up there and I walked into
the to the stand-up Club and I was like
I don't know what I'm walking into
exactly it's gonna be five five hundred
Mormons you know are they gonna have a
good sense of humor you know really and
truly it was one of I write about it in
my book it was one of the best nights of
my life so many it was in Salt Lake City
but just so many absolutely wonderful
people fun laughing laughing at
themselves it was it was just an
absolute blast tell me a little bit
about people don't know much about you
Toph you if you mentioned Utah to people
I think most people they think of skiing
they think of Carl Malone and and they
think of Mormon tell me a little bit
more about the most important thing we
talked earlier about the middle class
and what drives it that small business
ownership and in Utah there's 277
thousand businesses 99 99 % of those are
small business owners so that says a lot
about one of the cultures the way it is
we're a culture basically I said three
things a solutions services surplus we
are very entrepreneurs we're also always
thinking outside the box trying to
figure out how to make good things
happen so we get some wealth or
ourselves they give away a service we
love the server we're the community that
literally gets excited about our kids
going off to some crazy
the International place and nobody wants
to visit to store for two years and
we're excited about it so so we'll do
that because we understand that one
thing that brings us together and that's
why this country's gonna come together
in a big way we'll get through this we
fall in love with each other when we
serve each other that's in the end of
game that's what it comes down to so
we're very service culture the last one
is this we love to give back we love to
take our extra time and money to get
back what I love about being here to me
is home I've been talking about the
community I grew up in in deep south
Tallahassee when all I knew we're black
young entrepreneurs black coaches black
professors back business owners and
everybody saying you can do it you can
make it our goal is to become the best
race ever and show those guys wrong well
go up in that community I'm now I have
the same values so I feel really at home
it's really about those things are
taught but God can't free family respect
thinking outside the box service and and
and and I'll just say this this is why
this this district that I'm running it
is so important for those who are
watching why is district 4 important to
the rest of the country because this
between 1 and 3 of must haves are both
both parties the Democrats must have
this right now they only by Bill McAdams
there's a cluster team Republican Party
or district and noshiko Democrat but it
did so the Democrats must have it to
keep their power and you see what
they're doing they get power we must
have it to get our country back get back
to the culture we've been talking about
I feel very very proud and blessed to
represent a district that could truly be
the linchpin of our country now we're
talking I talked about earlier about
what could happen was to get that big
house back this seat can get it done and
we get our sill team together because of
this district that has the values we
have and that could be no more pleased
to be in person in a position that we
can actually help do that for our
country to finally start winning again
in a big way what kind of tracks are you
getting cuz you know it's funny the way
Twitter operates you know I see certain
personalities that are will bubble up
for a while and then I'll click a
profile I'll go oh this guy's running
for Congress in Utah this girl's running
for something in Florida something else
and you're kind of like oh well they're
sort of popular on Twitter or they make
sense here but it's a little hard to
tell from as an outsider well is this
gaining traction at home how can you
grade
sort of
your campaign is that are there weak
spots that you want to shore up you know
that kind of thing
very good I think the blessings that
I've had is that I'd never thought about
being a politician all these years I
mean literally did not happen to by this
time last year so up until this point I
came out of the book the person was
liberalism how to turn a good minute to
whiners whinnies and wimps and that guy
we only just run the same time that
October that's a good title it really is
but it is just by the same time that
company was doing is kneeling but I had
a chance to get on and share with
America my thoughts my pride in country
and that what I saw is really being
detrimental so I had a chance to develop
some friendships throughout the time and
so now that I that I'm running I really
have an opportunity to have exposure
that's been very advantageous for me we
have a community again because we're
we're very conservative that looks at
Fox so many people knew me somewhat even
though I was in a very small niche I was
working with at-risk kids so it wasn't
out in community a whole lot but it's
been an opportunity for me first of all
to really know this this this district a
lot more than I would have ever know
I've stayed a lot better because I'm now
out talking with people and what I'm
finding is that my message resonates we
all just want to have somebody who
wouldn't a stand and not not wilt and
not not feel ashamed or not apologize
and I try to be the end of the day when
God country family and race is the most
important thing before anything else
it's easy to stand it me is no big deal
because if that's being attacked then
you want to run to make sure you protect
all the above and and that's what I'm
finding out cross our country have
conservatives that really get it they
don't mind taking the head
they don't mind being called names cuz
it doesn't mean a thing matter of fact I
tell people call me names make sure
you're using your time right cuz it
doesn't impact me you might be wasting a
lot of time because it doesn't bother me
at all so and so together we get that
group together and we give this message
to those again who has been truly used
over the last few months abused the last
few months I think we have a point now
we can start to resonate and say yes you
know guys this worked together to get
our county back to where it was a few
months ago and this time know who the
enemy is and never go back and I think
that's where we we've come out of this
through this process with yeah
so I as I said I was on your website
this morning I was looking at the issues
that you knock out one one at a time
let's just do two or three that you're
that you're particularly passionate
about you you ollie
I'll even toss them up to you gimme two
or two or three that you really care
about that you think are the core issues
that can help you in very good burger
day again everything that I'm working
with is based on those promises life
liberty and pursuit of happiness that's
the bottom line for us to understand
that we have to be educated ignorant of
free can never be Thomas Jefferson that
is so powerful and and the left has
understood that a long time that's why
they've worked very hard to make sure we
stay ignorant it's the left you have a
true evil when you work diligently to
keep people hopeless and uneducated
that's what I call evil you know to the
state of California with 75% of
blackboard state of California 2017
cannot pass standard reading and writing
test when young people cannot read and
write we're not going to talk about
space course we're not gonna have
conversations like this you're gonna
turn on the network's and be driven by
emotion because they have no hope no way
of thinking no man reasoning their
memory descriptors the connection with a
God in heaven will never ever happen and
you go to every single threshold every
single city that's owned by the leftist
by the Democrats you've seen the exact
same thing hopelessness anger and
literacy so education is gonna be a big
day it's gonna be a big piece now the
other part of Education is that what
they've done in higher education it's
not just the poor kids that are being
attacked is it's the rest of our kids
there's our middle class we raise our
kids in a great environment we send them
off to get a degree they come back as
little marxist hating our country and
that they would think at all about
reasoning they've been doing this for so
long and now you see it in the streets
across the country and Tifa they're now
black kids they're here they're middle
class
yuppie my days yuppies what was cool I'm
not the still cooler or what but there
can their kids who have the wealth but
they hate our country what I think we
should do is version of it as I told us
earlier this put together a program and
an understanding of what is expected
about colleges they want they want they
want our money they first of all we have
to see transparency how much is
basically how much of this
seating and when what areas we need as a
country if they don't hit those areas
those those bills those metrics we get
our money we take it back put it
someplace else so education is the first
thing one of the things that just warmed
my heart really warmed my heart when I
saw the rice in Minneapolis they had
this video of these black owners black
businesses just next to each other yeah
and in the window black owned a big
black deck back on and this was an
opportunity for all of us to see what a
Passover looks like because the the
locust in the the pillage of Lula's
passed over these businesses why because
it was this ar-15 sitting there on his
stove as a state these kids knowing that
it is show up here you can have some it
some issues they passed by the go to
those companies those businesses that
still believe in the bureaucracy is
gonna take gonna save them so those are
the two top things is education
education will allow us to have that
mindset to go out build our own
businesses build our property which is
important that's what the pursuit of
happiness was in place for pursuit of
property when that property will be
tangible property intellectual property
spiritual property passed down through
our kids our name those things we work
our lives to build at the end of the day
we on our last breath which is Babel to
say I'm so glad I live because this is
my legacy that's what a property was
truly means in order to protect that we
need to be educated to think about what
it looks like and has a vision to get
there we also have to have the tools
protect every single step of the way so
nobody can come in and steal it from us
and we now understand we talked about
needing to have that that ability go to
these cities were they were just let
loose evils just let loose in these
cities we start to see what it really
looks like and where we can never let
that happen
and I like that do you think that that
mindset of how to conquer all of this is
really the same mindset whether you're
an entrepreneur or a professional
athlete or a politician that really
wants to change things properly that it
is purely a mindset of I am going to
dedicate myself to this relentlessly and
see it fit and maybe that's why you can
see it as a former NFL player where some
people can't quite see it because you
know there's this idea that somehow
victimhood
gives you virtue these days or can't
someone else
stupid org or the SIS the rules are so
against me that I can't do it but it's
like if we think of all of our heroes
our sports heroes or fictional heroes
they did it they said it doesn't matter
how messed up the game is I'm gonna win
I'm gonna fix it and you know that's
that's what comes out of a healthy
environment that's what came out of my
community growing up your parents when
we had the idea first of all life is not
always quote fair life is difficult and
if people are going to try to slow you
down but if you have the tenacity if you
can dream because you've educated
yourself to know this possible
and you have the faith know that that
you're just especially anybody else then
we can overcome those obstacles the
problem with having in my community and
we're now having across the country and
I say this as off as I can what
destroyed my community was turned it
upside down so we see kids now that are
acting like victims and it's destroying
their own properties it was not white
supremacist has never has been white
supremacist we beat out white
supremacists it's been black elitist
it's been those with stealth those who
look like me those who talk like me
those who put their arms around said you
know we're gonna make things right and
make things so just all fear and it's
still out there going they go to
Congress the black caucus the
n-double-a-cp
your name them the elitist instead of
giving us hope and tell us what we can
do they purposely put in place
impediments they put in laws that make
sure the poor cannot become become
wealthy a little class to make sure that
our poor black kids that never be
educated why cuz they're stuck because
of this anti choice that these black it
leaders will vote for and stand for and
see their people destroyed because they
don't care so it is truly elite ISM
across the board that's our enemy and
I'll say this if we go ahead and educate
ourselves not to what with the
propaganda of the leftist educate
ourselves to our history educate
ourselves to what we two people done I
tell you Dave if we did that I'm just
real quick story I would never ever ever
I'm not a rate of racism never will be
but what my point is but particularly
for our German and Mexican Americans
will ever look down or feel bad about
that race those people why because
Martin when my great-great-grandfather
came here had been abolished
relationship they escaped
north south carolina's plantation and
Burgess plantation they went this
southern and western route of the
Underground Railroad guess who was who
was making that happen
Christian German Americans and Mexican
Americans opening their doors open the
feels phantom gave them hope along the
way and what happened when that that
trip out west not only did my
great-great grandfather I understand he
could make great things happen but he
was able to forgive and we're not to be
a successful entrepreneur owned 102
acres of land that he bought in to a or
two years it can pay a pillar of his
community because along the way this
travel he realized that all white people
aren't bad they're good people out there
and he had to be a Christian he started
the first black elementary school and
first first like Church well my point is
this once we learned the stories of what
we've done together we find that
happening all over the place it's not
it's not a special case we have always
done that but we have to educate
ourselves to that point and once we do
that we can break loose of this the
racist process that's been put upon us
by the Democratic Party that my friend
is what America is all about I think I
think my pretty close you got it that's
who we are and and the most powerful
words in a history of mankind that we
sometimes just throw out there and we
don't quite get it's never been done
this way it's three empowering words
that has spawned an experiment that is
truly given freedom to the entire world
We the People We the People vs other
says that we control our future we can
divide our our everything about our
family our business our jobs how we deal
with people and we together collectively
can elect a president 2016 that nobody
saw coming we could figure out some
things that we have no idea how we did
ever how do we do that seriously with so
many guys out there how do we pull that
one off
because all right well listen I know
that I didn't want to be I know you
didn't want to be a politician but now
I'm gonna see if you're doing it
properly cuz I'm gonna give you the last
word to pimp out your website and your
comfort and pain and the whole thing
let's see it lets see it thank you for
this opportunity to a Brutus for Utah
please join us please support us let's
get out Congress Mac let's give this
team still team in place and this when
our country and just win baby we can do
that again for sure
I look forward to seeing you again my
friend will do Gutfeld again I'm sure
and you know next time I wear shorts
sometimes don't I'm on good oh we gotta
get we gotta get you in some shorts or a
bathing I'll send you something oh my
goodness oh dear Dave I don't know if
I'll do it but I'm welcome to try it and
think about it for sure okay all right
good luck very Jess thank you thank you
buddy
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell